irgendwie kommt er einem bekannt vor
nun 125 jahre nach seinem tod wird er
ins richtige licht gerückt dieser mann
hat die moderne schweiz geprägt wie kein
anderer
trotzdem kennen ihn heute die wenigsten
wer war alfred escher
wir bauen gründete wichtige banken weil
ich gründete verbindet sich
aus
der mit den zügen und der mit der bank
ja genau und der mit der gotthardbahn
mehr als ein jahrhundert war er in der
versenkung verschwunden in den
schulbüchern wird er kaum erwähnt
jetzt zum 125-jährigen gott hat jubiläum
wird er von den schweizer
wirtschaftsführer als vordenker auf den
schild gehoben
sogar ein zug wird nach ihn getauft
dieser mann war ein pionier dem unser
land viel verdankt alfred escher hat er
recht eigentlich die moderne schweiz
angeschlossen sein wirtschaftliches und
politisches wirken ist gigantisch ja
geradezu moment da die erkenntnis dass
alfred escher im neunzehnten jahrhundert
die herausragende persönlichkeit war hat
sich inzwischen ganz offenbar
durchgesetzt
organisiert von der beste oder damalige
zeit gegenüber den verbrauchern eine
prämie im nachhinein vorbild charakter
über wochen eine jubiläumsfahrt und eine
reise zurück ins leben des ersten
schweizer wirtschaftsbooms
[Musik]
die schweiz ist zu beginn des 19
jahrhunderts ein beschaulicher agrar
start in den städten regiert das
großbürgertum obwohl alfred escher 1819
in einer der reichsten patrizierfamilien
zürichs hineingeboren wird ist eher ein
außenseiter
seine familie hatte mit spekulationen
halt zürich in den ruin getrieben und
die schulden nicht zurückgezahlt
mit wohnsitznahme in bell war außerhalb
der stadt macht vater es den bruch mit
dem konservativen zürich noch
offensichtlicher
[Musik]
sohn alfred studiert jura
aufgrund von deiner verschiedene brüche
zwischen der familie und dem
konservative alte tür ist es eigentlich
naheliegend und logisch dass die alfred
ist eine politische karriere machen
das heißt erteile ich nur eine
möglichkeit alternative da sind die
radikal liberalen und union aus hunger
das sind hier wohnen neue spitze wählen
und wähle die alte zöpfe abschneiden und
peter hat sich alfred escher abschloss
dh am anfang ein radikal liberalen stark
zentralstaat wett und welche mit dem
föderalismus in der schweiz und ein
neues schweiz weiter moderne schweiz
wenn und aber nicht mit dem autor der
sich die stanz ihre von der
konservativen in zürich
1844 gewinnen die radikal liberalen in
zürich die mehrheit und kommen
sukzessive auch in anderen kantonen an
die macht beseelt von ihren visionen und
geprägt von der liberalen bewegung in
ganz europa gründen sie 1848 den neuen
bundestag
gern wird bundeshauptstadt alfred escher
erst 29 wird in den nationalrat gewählt
sein freund jonas furrer wird erster
bundespräsident der schweiz
fürs tatendrang macht ihn schnell zum
führenden kopf der liberalen
der alfred escher hat die mit fenster
innen bleibt wo es nachher alfred könne
mit seiner liberalen freunde der schweiz
baue moderne schweiz vor 88 84 60er
jahren in dem kleinen
wirtschaftspolitische
wirtschaftsliberale zeitfenster womit
weichheit könne stelle wo möglichst nahe
sein können aufbauen und das ist eine
einmalige chance xiii und die chance
hätte er packt und reiht er sich
engagiert für schwyz für das land und
auf die kante und syrien
in zürich findet der gütertransport
immer noch auf dem wasser statt
anstelle der noblen bahnhofstraße gibt
es den stinkenden frischen graben
das umliegende europa hingegen verändert
sich rasant
der brite george stephenson hat die
eisenbahn erfunden
euphorie macht sich breit und es wird
gebaut was das zeug hält
die schweiz jedoch ist im europäischen
eisenbahnnetz ein weißer fleck mit einer
einzigen ausnahme
die spanisch brötli bahn 23 kilometer
schiene zwischen zürich und baden
[Musik]
schweizweit gefragt verschlafe schweiz
hat sich stritten um konfessionelle
frage um frage aber da nicht die
entscheidende frage für die zukunft vom
land für die wirtschaftspolitischen
entwickelt ich bin nicht erfreut
nachgang an die schnur durfte
prioritätenliste gestanden
und jetzt wo der alfred escher 1848 und
nationalrat worten ist erzieher
regierungsrat wurde hat er gemerkt also
bis moskau
die schweiz muss man voranbringen die
schweiz muss man modernisieren und hat
er sich allmählich mit ihren anfragen
[Musik]
alfred escher lanciert die diskussion
und sagt im nationalrat 1849
es tauchen pläne auf gemäß denen die
bahnen um die schweiz herumgeführt
werden soll
der schweiz droht somit die gefahr
gänzlich umgangen zu werden
von seinem bell war in zürich aus nimmt
alfred escher kontakt auf mit anderen
kantonen und mit dem ausland
die entscheidende frage ist soll der
staat oder sollen private eisenbahnen
bauen
wie immer wenn alfred escher etwas
beschäftigt führte darüber einen regen
briefwechsel mit seinen vertrauten aus
dem liberalen lager
er und sein freund johann jakob rütimann
sind sich einig die eidgenossenschaft
kann weder selbst bauern noch zinsen
garantieren
sie muss sich also darauf beschränken
ein explorations gesetz zu erlassen
der sich allmählich denn ganz klar
positioniert auf die siedler von der
privatwirtschaft das heißt es sind nur
privat die woche in dieser bahn bau weil
der rückstand wohl schweiz gegenüber
russland ist nicht möglich dass der
staat wenn man starke ribana wurde bauer
dass wir den rückstand an die eu wolle
1852 verabschiedet der nationalrat das
erste eisenbahngesetz der schweiz
es kommt wie er will private dürfen
eisenbahnen bauen
aus heutiger sicht hat es damit etwas
angestoßen was die zukunft der schweiz
entscheidend geprägt und vorwärts
gebracht hat wo kein der streit um das
grundstück für den report eine
einzigartige situation sieht dass er den
aufbruch in europa natürlich geht das
manchmal auch sehr dass ich dort meine
ganze infrastrukturellen asbeck händler
sehr große rolle gespielt und da hat man
natürlich vielleicht sogar über ein
gewisses ihn einfach könig wies die
leiche erbringen
dank stimmt dass man auch wieso er sich
aber auch der willenskraft
das eisenbahngesetz führt in der schweiz
zu einer eigentlichen goldgräberstimmung
überall entstehen privaten
eisenbahngesellschaften und alle kämpfen
darum die besten linienführungen zu
bekommen 1855 alleine werden in der
schweiz 170 kilometer schienen verlegt
ist alfred escher bis 1852 vor allem
politisch tätig steigt er nun auch als
unternehmer ins eisenbahn geschäft ein
und gründet die nordost bahnen sein ziel
möglichst schnell eisenbahn kilometer zu
legen und den anschluss ans ausland zu
schaffen
die nordost bahn wird bald zur größten
eisenbahngesellschaft der schweiz
[Musik]
die nötigen kantonalen konzessionen kann
sich alfred escher der neben seinem
nationalratsmandat noch zürcher kantons
und regierungsrat ist problemlos
organisieren
[Musik]
schnell wird klar das eisenbahngeschäft
ist kapitalintensiv
das geld für seine expansionspläne muss
sich alfred escher im ausland beschaffen
die ausländische kapitalgeber und genau
bedingungen diktiert und da seid einig
mal frischer notfall dass ich bis wo das
innere politische vision die
unabhängigkeit vor die schweiz und die
unabhängigkeit von der schweiz wenn er
das verstand hat sich nicht nur darin
zeige dass man jetzt diese bahnlinie
gebaut sondern die unabhängigkeit für
ihn ist dass es eigentlich auf schweizer
banken gibt das quasi schweiz dort
entscheide wo diese bahnlinie touren
führen oder das schweizer interesse zu
entscheiden welche dieser beiden
gesellschaften miteinander fusionieren
dass man das nicht in paris oder in
london oder in frankfurt wird entscheide
sondern in syrien und die schweiz
[Musik]
1856 gründet alfred escher die
kreditanstalt um damit seine nordost
bahn zu finanzieren
kurz darauf folgt die rentenanstalt
seinen freunden juristischen berater
johann jakob rüttimann nimmt ihr bei der
kreditanstalt in den verwaltungsrat
dass seine beiden unternehmen zürich und
damit die schweiz zum grössten
finanzplatz europas machen würden
damals noch niemand gründe für den
kredit am start ich denke halt in die
gussform alfred escher weil kredit an
statische die erste und ethisch die
grossbank wo natürlich auch nie so bahn
bereichen kanton zürich sondern auch in
der ganzen schweiz wirtschaftlich
vorhaben unterstützt hat kapital geld
zur verfügung gestellt hat und 3
natürlich den fuß
wer geld überholt oder welches
unternehmen kein geld über hunt und
aufgrund von dem hat er natürlich viel
mehr jetzt in fluss kam mit inneren
eigenen hausbank als vorher
manfred eichers jubiläumszug ist in
luzern angekommen
genau wie vor 125 jahren an der großen
eröffnungsfeier für die gotthardbahn
geht's zuerst aufs schiff bevor im hotel
schweizerhof das große die näh serviert
wird
was hält man in politik und wirtschaft
heute vom großen pionier alfred escher
die zentrale eigenschaften und was unter
spezieller ist die verbindung wirtschaft
ruiniert sich aber politik braucht doch
da macht das einzigartige zusätzlich
nehmen wollte und vor inflation wäre er
wird ja unterschiedliche leben aber auch
ohne große rücksicht notwendig bis
verfolgt ist das projekt zuvor
das zeichnet die nase hat system
wirklich
er hat sich nicht davon abbringen das
ist wahrscheinlich der erfolg von den
sitzen
vermutlich ja es geht natürlich nur wenn
es brennt und das ziel hängt und klaus
mit allen mitteln verfolgen aber man hat
immer die gleichen instrumente lesen zu
setzen
mit der nordosten der creditanstalt und
allen seinen politischen ämtern hat
alfred escher in den 50er jahren
tatsächlich sehr viele möglichkeiten um
die geschicke der schweiz zu lenken
auch nachdem ihr 1855 als zürcher
regierungsrat zurück getreten ist nimmt
er ungebremst einfluss auf die wichtigen
geschäfte im kanton erhält politische
clubs und gesellschaft begründet man
muss sich vorstellen
pattaya im heutige verständlich seit
damals non gaap und fischerei fange
plattform für seine politische freunde
für seine liberale ideen eine vor der
wichtigste ist mittwoch gesellschaft sie
günstig gesellschaft hätte er gründet
von erden sind im kanton zürich zwei
märkte aus der ganzen schweiz
und wenn er quasi politisiert wurde
personalpolitische sachpolitische
diskutiert hat wo man entscheid gefällt
hat der seite zur geführt dass große
wichtige geschäft eigentlich im
kantonsrat sehr schnell über die bühne
gegangen sind innerhalb von wenigen
minuten haben das diskutiert weil
eigentlich die eher weicher sind bereits
vorher vom alfred escher gestellt worden
die mittwoch gesellschaft oder in der
kunst gesellschaft
[Musik]
die meisten dieser geschäfte werden
durch den eisenbahnbau ausgelöst dank
eschers einfluss wird beispielsweise die
eidgenössische technische hochschule die
eth in zürich angesiedelt denn für die
erweiterung des schienennetzes braucht
es ingenieure und technisches personal
und dieses muss irgendwo ausgebildet
werden
[Musik]
1861 lasiert escher auch das projekt für
einen neuen zürcher hauptbahnhof nicht
ganz uneigennützig denn nur so kann er
sicher stellen dass ein zürich als
wirtschafts und industriestandort
wichtig bleibt
zürich punkt
alfred escher befindet sich auf dem
höhepunkt seiner macht zwar von zürich
oder heimliche könig der schweiz wetter
nun genannt und tatsächlich mit seinen
politischen einfluss und seinen
verschiedenen ämtern in der
privatwirtschaft kann er schalten und
walten wie er will
überall zieht er die fäden
aufgrund einer verschiedene
wirtschaftspolitische plattform hat der
möglichkeit dass er sie nie politische
freunde
die liberale hat keine idee
entsprechenden ämter inne auf die
wirtschaft kredite als verwaltungsrat
der verwaltungsratssitzung absätze und
weiter natürlich lloret da sie in die
politische freunde
die entsprechende funktion erinnert welt
werden
aber nicht nur das auch im bundesrat
kann er jederzeit einfluss nehmen so
schreibt er an seinen freund und
bundesrat jacobs als es um die
bewilligung des bundes für die
kreditanstalt geht wenn du die
beiliegende nachträgliche eingabe der
handelskammer zuhanden der regierung
rechtzeitig zu überweisen die güte
hättest könnte sie heute nachmittag noch
behandelt werden
von seinen freunden im bundesrat wird
zudem stets über alle details informiert
der eisenbahn baron weiß einfach alles
und kann entsprechend handeln
der heutige verkehrsminister moritz
leuenberger hat nicht annähernd so viel
macht den wunsch möglichst rasch und
ohne lästige kommissionssitzungen und
volksabstimmung bist du rietz 2000
freien unternehmer vielleicht kann aber
jetzt leben wir innere direkter
demokratie ich glaube an die direkte
demokratie und die direkt die demokratie
ich doch immerhin in der lage also eines
kita projekt mit mehr dass beschlüsse in
viele volksabstimmung
das projekt ist zu einmal beschlossen
worden er finanziere ich einmal
beschlossen wurde
dallas verlor die internazionale rettig
ich beschlossen oder alles in
volksabstimmungen und jetzt wird es baut
und die ganze welt beneidet äußerung
alle diese hürden muss es noch nicht
nehmen
warum ist der eigentlich nicht als
bundesrat geworden fragt man sich
tatsächlich wird der zweimal angefragt
winkt aber immer ab er ist ein
familienmensch sie so sehr starke
beziehung zu seiner mutter
und es zeigt sich eine show ist der
jugend jahre als student immer wenn da
alfred escher haben sofort vor dh wenn
ihr auslandssemester gemacht hat oder
wenn er auf reisen gegangen ist eine
reichlich überspitzt formuliert die
schlagworte und dass sich auto group
sieben seiten er wird die erneuert und
bayern sondern ein vitales leben bliebe
die jubiläums gesellschaft ist im hotel
schweizerhof angekommen das setting des
genesis bis in alle details dem fest zur
gotthard eröffnung vor 125 jahren
nachempfunden
gastgeberin credit suisse die ihren
gründervater esche auf diese weise ehrt
schuld keine kosten und
verwaltungsratspräsident kielholz ist
optimistisch dass es mit dem aufschwung
in der schweiz nochmals so weitergeht
wie zu kaisers zeiten
danke dir ja das sind wir dem ziel
was ganz großes schiff gehörte das
witzigste gesellschaft und der student
vor meine ganz große schockwellen der
firma derzeit mehrere jahre eine
migration in der mann der über für
hochqualifizierte erweitert das land
weiterbringen
er befindet sich also auf dem höhepunkt
seiner macht und auch privat scheint
sich beim arbeitswütigen und ehrgeizigen
vision er alles zum guten zu wenden
1857 heiratet er die 20 jahre jüngere
augusta übel
interessant ist dass eric roth hat die
möglichkeit dass er das zerrüttete
verhältnis zu malte züri mit
regierungspolitik hätte wieder gerne
probieren zum kritik macht kreisrekord
der winterthurer kurorte sondern er
hortet als jähriger mann 19 jährige die
eigentlich in zürich
niemand kennt und foto annett verwurzelt
ist
bald kommt seine erste tochter lydia zur
welt genannt nach elias mutter
[Musik]
1861 wird es zweite tochter hedwig
geboren
aber sein glück ist von kurzer dauer nun
folgt eine ganze reihe von schweren
schicksalsschlägen eineinhalb jahre nach
der geburt stirbt tochter hedwig an
seinen alten freund und bundesrat jacobs
schreibt alfred escher heute früh wurde
hedwig von einer lungenentzündung
befallen die so heftig wurde dass ihr
das blühende kind schon um 1130
vormittags zum opfer fiel
du kannst dir denken wie groß unsere
aller schmerz ist
ich weiß dass du in teur freundschaft
mit fühlst
aber es kommt noch schlimmer
zwei jahre später muss acer seine junge
frau zu grabe tragen
als sein kleiner freund kasperle brechts
mackie ihr zu ehren seine tochter august
nennt schreibtische gerührt zurück du
kannst dir denken das sich durch diesen
namen der neugeborenen um so näher
gebracht werde
lasst mich hier über nicht weiter
sprechen
die sitze in der verfassungskommission
und musste er wehmut die mich ergreift
meister zu werden suchen
[Musik]
nach nur sieben jahren ehe steht alfred
escher mit tochter lydia alleine da
delete wahrscheinlich eher höflich an
berater platz biete creditanstalt wie
manfred esser sie sitzt im
verwaltungsrat sei mit sieht der vater
begleitete als jungs mehrheitlich in
nardo sparen als einziger vom
direktorium das heißt dass michael wax
eigentlich nicht so gut wie andere
knightley damals auf taxis
diese umstände werden wie die us leben
prägen
und sie zeigen auch eine seite von
alfred escher die in den ganzen
jubiläumsfeierlichkeiten zu seinen ehren
schnell vergessen wird
darüber gerät wie die familiäre
situation ist besser
das teil ist das ja die familiäre
situation mit seiner tochter und sie ist
aber wahrscheinlich sage trägt man ganz
stark verformte völlig unter deiner wahl
bei mir persönlichkeit so weil
entwickler das sehr grüne bestaunen
also ich muss sagen ich bin ein grosser
nächsten verein aber vor lauter freude
betroffen ist
das ist natürlich ein negatives in der
intercard
ende 1860 ändert sich auch politisch
einiges die liberalen in zürich
verlieren die mehrheit in der regierung
und im parlament von essers alten
freunden und politischen verbündeten
stirbt einer nach dem anderen
wir werden immer weniger schreibt alfred
escher
demokraten betreten das politische
parkett und gewinnen an boden
die volksrechte initiative und
referendum werden eingeführt eschers
allmacht beginnt zu drücken
es hat eigentlich den zwangsläufig über
als lüge politiker alfred escher
sie sind in einer sachfrage betreiben
dass es einfach willi und immer mega
einfach die dominanz vor dem alfred
escher einfach nimmer akzeptierten die
opposition gegen ihn informiert sich nur
langsam
noch funktioniert das system escher und
der unermüdliche stürzt sich voller
engagement ins größte projekt seines
lebens er schreibt das zustandekommen
einer schweizerischen alpen bahn
erscheint mir von tag zu tag wichtiger
und dringlicher es wird mir immer klarer
dass die schweiz ohne eine den walliser
alpen durchbrechen der eisenbahn zu
einem von dem großen welt verkehr
umgangen und verlassenen eilande
herabsinken müsste
schon seit den 50er jahren gibt es pläne
für eine nord süd achse besser
favorisiert die luke mania variante das
ändert sich in den 60er jahren
[Musik]
es schränkte eigentlich um wird
plötzlich gotthard befürworter mit
konkrete projekte mit wo machbar sind
bugsiert der gotthard ist eine gar nicht
viel teurer wir der lukmanier und der
gothaer schau technisch machbar und wo
das klar ist dass der grund haben die
zwing war ich hätte gott hat viel
größere chance noch einmal lieber allein
der gotthard lied einfach viel besser
der kroate liegt im nord-süd-verkehr die
motive der schweiz der große teil für
die schweizer konzerns hin durfte sich
von gott hat sie das seil ziehen in bern
um die wichtige nord süd route dauert
jahre
nicht viel anders als heute auch bei der
nähert wurde um die richtige route
gerungen
zwischen gotthard und lötschberg
verkehrsminister moritz leuenberger
die haben es kühlt sich nicht viel
verändert
also immer noch ist die rivalität
zwischen werner und gott hat die andere
in rom
mit der gotthard frist ist alles kalr
lang veröffentliche verkehr vor mir mein
finanzieren wo lötschberg basistunnel
eröffnet worden ist hat gotthard jahr
ist die cs plant ihres 125 jahr jubiläum
bucher vorwärts machen und medien
abgeben müssen
intervenieren das ist zum teil nicht
viel
in der zeit spielt am schluss bismarcks
deutschland das zünglein an der waage
großer politischer militär strategische
überlegungen ich verbreite und fürst die
nummern der gotthard infracor wählen
der lukmanier der grenze zu österreich
österreich ungarn wahrscheinlichkeit
militär strategisch nur dieses konzept
passt von bismarck und bismarck hat eine
schlagseite wird diese nummer beteilige
substanziell anderer nord-süd-verbindung
wenn der gotthard baut wird der druck
bismarcks aus der retrospektive ein
segen für die schweiz
dies jedenfalls ist der allgemeine tenor
an der gotthard jubiläumsfeier der
gotthard- und der von seiner bedeutung
im neunzehnten jahrhundert oft mit dem
satz genau verglichen wurde war nicht
nur das duo zu italien sondern zu einer
welt eine eigentliche globalisierung
schritt für die damalige gesellschaft
auch wenn man das sicher noch nicht so
genannt haben
alfred escher wird zur treibenden kraft
und zum großen lobbyisten für das
gotthard projekt er schreibt im innern
der schweiz war schwere arbeit zu
verrichten vielleicht die schwerste
hier kamen zu den schwierigkeiten in der
sache noch die vielen kantonen mit denen
man zu tun hatte
in jedem wieder eine andere anschauung
und auch musste alles unter einen hut
gebracht werden
im bundesrat allerdings wäsche ab 1866
ein schärferer wind entgegen
mit dem aargauer emil welti gibt es
einen neuen starken mann in bern
welty steht für eine neue politiker
generation der jurist aus zurzach stammt
aus dem kleinbürgertum und hat sich
heraf gedient er gehört nicht mehr zur
gründergeneration der schweiz sondern
schon zu den bewahrern und verwaltern
die einen stärkeren zentralstaat fordern
ganz im gegensatz zu escher dieser
möchte auch die gotthardbahn durch eine
private trägerschaft bauen lassen
die welt die tut sich einig medulin
führte privat bau im kreml welt die auf
die sitte vom vom staatschef die sie
verdienen wo seit der staat muss dieser
bahngesellschaften übernahm aber der
welt ich an 1866 und ein bundesrat
gewählt wird
der stärke jahrhundert und erzählt wie
er macht vereinigt sind und gemacht
feilen sind damals noch von manfred
stock sie auf die sitte vereine oder
privat bahnbau favorisieren und umsätze
auch wenn die opposition gegen esch
erwächst
er bleibt das zugpferd für das
goldprojekt an ihm kommt niemand vorbei
das sei natürlich jetzt eine über windig
braucht für die bundesrat dass man sich
dort für den frieden entscheiden obwohl
dass man genau wüsste dass sie keine
andere wahl
aber es ist politisch ein heikles 8 und
da hatte bundesrat sich zurück und seite
mit welt die engagiert zum die
verhandlungen mit mal kritische rufe und
mit welchem einen headhunter jetzt zudem
alfred escher und hätten fragt übernimmt
wir die der direktions position vor dem
gotthard unternehmen wird über ein und
das macht seine ämter in der
privatwirtschaft will er aber behalten
einzig bei der nord ost bahn tritt er
als direktor zurück wird aber
verwaltungsratspräsident
die mühselige reiserei über den gotthard
soll bald ein ende haben
1871 wird die gotthard gesellschaft als
private aktiengesellschaft gegründet
italien deutschland und die kantone
beteiligen sich an der finanzierung
bern will aber mitreden was fahrplan
güterverkehr und finanzen anbelangt ein
konstrukt das heute nicht mehr in frage
kommen würde
als großes bauwerk wird nähert nur durch
das start durchgeführt werden ua die
risiken große risiken mit sich bringt
hat tatsächlich über entsprechend der
natürlich den finanzerträgen damit es
möglichst nicht zu überraschungen zu
lasten der steuerzahler kommt mit
finanziellen überraschungen muss man
beim bau der gotthardbahn schon fast
rechnen
der genfer senior lief erhält den
auftrag am anfang läuft alles rund aber
bald ist klar die veranschlagten 187
millionen franken reichen nicht aus es
ist nicht einfach irgendwo des tunnels
sie wo man baut sondern mir hätte ein 15
kilometer langer tunnel messebauer natur
das gotthardmassiv tore wo man absolut
geologisch nur im griff kriegen keine
reserven gebaut entsprechen die und so
weiter das hat dazu geführt dass einfach
vater clark sie ist jetzt mutiger sich
dass er seit nyse zu rauschen
überschritten
der bau des gotthardtunnels fällt in
eine zeit wo der eisenbahnbau in ganz
europa in eine krise schlittern
der markt ist überhitzt die aktienkurse
fallen
alfred escher erhält viele böse briefe
von enttäuschten aktionären dem
augenblick wo die kurs zu können wo
dividende zu können ich bin natürlich
winfried er mich frustriert jetzt fühlen
wie falsch investiert und das wird jetzt
das eine die breite kreise von der
schweizer bevölkerung bevölkerung das
misstrauen das missbehagen gegen die
spekulation gegen diese
bahngesellschaften größer und größer
wird und so hofft man natürlich ein
sündenbock der sündenbock ist der kopf
wird einigen gesellschaften vor der
direkter direktionspräsident alfred
escher in dem moment rächt sich dass es
so lange so viel macht auf sich
vereinigt hat und dass er sie so
rücksichtslos ausgeübt hat das liberale
establishment kommt extrem unter druck
in zürich übernehmen die demokraten die
macht wenn er zieht genussvoll auf
revanche
die mit sich vor der demokratischen
bewegung im kanton zürich schlager und
hat die bundes barone mit vehemenz
bekämpft republikaner aber demokratisch
ist fan ist die pionierin er ist scharf
aber sie wirklich überlief ergangen
tatsächlich die arbeitsbedingungen am
gotthard sind schlecht und das
jahrhundertwerk fordert viele opfer
die kosten laufen je länger je mehr aus
dem ruder bundesrat mlt beginnt sich von
escher zu distanzieren
auf komfort der ganze situation hat sich
zeige dass alle musste sich vom welt
jetzt wurde ein sündenbock gefunden
werden und der sündenbock hat muss sie
sich von wählt die nummer der alfred ist
auch ohne sie wäre wenn es nur total
fertig sie war während er selber
natürlich in frack und gemüse irgendeine
andere person finde wo die er
verantwortlich muss sich neu und das ist
die sicht von welt hätte es nur noch
eine dvd sie die kostenüberschreitungen
werden für alfred escher zum
stolperstein wird er sie eigentlich
erstaunlich positiver sich das
eigentlich trotz erhalt eine
unwägbarkeit das kostenüberschreitung
letztlich als 20 millionen franken
ausgemacht hat und die 20 millionen
franken auf das gesamte budget 187
millionen franken das sind elf prozent
stellen überschritten und dann mal
wieder locker die hütte gezielt bis mehr
sohnes großes projekt findet dort wo mit
media elf prozent überschritten
verglichen mit der nähert ist das
tatsächlich nicht schien die nähert
kommt mittlerweile rund doppelt so teuer
wie geplant
nur hat man heute in der direkten
demokratie originelle möglichkeiten um
mehrkosten nicht mehr als
kostenüberschreitungen deklarieren zu
müssen
nach vollständiger schnittige ins in
wien ist das damals sky hat gibt es
nicht und da sind ja ebert lehre zur
geburt und mit dass projekte so
organisiert dass das nicht möglich ist
natürlich und natur als als auf dem
damals folgt aber will bewusst
beschlossen worden ist
ausgabe 21
das sind demokratische beschlüsse in ein
einziger punkt sind sind richter
entstand wo mit verlust und das betrifft
die ausschreibung und die rekurs vor
unterlagen firmen wohl ziemliche
verzögerungen herweg führte 1877 wird es
für alfred escher richtig ungemütlich
es hagelt kritik und häme von allen
seiten das millionenloch in der gotthard
kasse muss gestoppt werden und der
bundesrat um emilie welti beginnt es
systematisch zu demontieren
die machtfülle eschers sei hinderlich
für die nötigen mehrheiten zur nach
finanzierung des gotthards schreibt welt
die an escher und fordert von ihm den
rücktritt aus dem verwaltungsrat der
creditanstalt
sie denn eigentlich probiere zum thema
sukzessive in eine schlechte position
jetzt druck das ist aber nur einfach
weil die wirtschaftspolitische stärke
immer noch die wirtschaftliche macht und
das ist wirklich schwierige situation
zum sonnen dominant die person quasi
aufs abstellgleis schieben
alfred escher tritt zurück um wie die
kreditanstalt schreibt seine kraft ganz
und ungeteilt den gefährdeten nationalen
unternehmen der gotthardbahn zu widmen
als nur wenige monate später der
nachtragskredit zu gott hat finanzierung
von jedem einzelnen kanton also auch von
zürich bewilligt werden muss kommt welt
die chance alfred escher ganz
loszuwerden
das zürcher volk müsse sich entscheiden
will man nach subvention bewillige oder
will man das nicht bewilligen und der
alfred stock seite er möchte sofort
informiert werden
zu welcher tages zieht auch immer dass
die resultat im kanton zürich bekannt
sind oder sich dann am morgen um halb
betrug sie wo die büros jänner zum
alfred escher ist belarus am morgen um
halb drei und seit alfred escher ford
funde als impuls dvd schaffen und der
nette bürger jener börse im alfred
escher mitteilen dass in eigene kannte
und syrien hervor lag klar abgrenzt und
das ist sehr sehr schmerzhaft ziehvater
alfred escher alfred escher so ist
überliefert ist als impuls standard mit
einer hand trat stirn eine lange und
wieder andere hand hat er sich abstützt
als impuls und deren schreie aus low und
high mich dafür sagte stampfer und
missouri bundesrat welti nutzt die
politische niederlage es um ihm den
entscheidenden schlag zu versetzen
er zwingt ihn von seinem posten als
direktionspräsident der gotthard
gesellschaft zurückzutreten
ich muss es ohne umschweife sagen so
leid es mir tut das eine reihe der
besten freunde unsere sache das opfer
ihres rücktritts für das gelingen des
werkes erforderlich hält schreibt wälti
also letztlich bundesrat wählt die und
die freisinnige freund und weil die oma
einst alfred escher kopf wird und man
muss sagen dass eigentlich die
freisinnigen die eigene partei vom es
schlachtbank geführt sind
nur vier tage nach diesem brief legt
alfred escher sein amt als
direktionspräsident nieder
es ist die bitterste niederlage seines
lebens
der visionäre wirtschaftskrimi ist
gescheitert
[Musik]
alfred escher fall hätte tiefer nicht
sein können
wie interpretiert man heute seinen
niedergang
dass ich nichts weiß auch wo in der
schweizer wald ist es interessenten und
trainiert ich würde sagen genetisch ganz
wesentlicher punkt wurde in hombruch
demokratisch jährigen gefunden und
letztlich aus einem land das immer war
damit wachse das management bei schon
bin ich auch ein bisschen findet dass
die aber kräftig sein abgewertet in der
stadt zürich ist typisch diego der die
geworden gebe streit unter denen man
kräfte hat sagt geschlagen haben wir
haben durch das denkmal der zweite mann
und frau fest
wir sind das volk und das ist spitze
das ist vielleicht auch beruflich
natürlich man de facto es opfer wurden
von klima gerechtigkeit haben probiert
neue folgen
dass sie vor dem projekt take that
sondern vielleicht schafft kommt
hätte hier alfred escher wird
vollständig demontiert
welche will ihn nicht einmal mehr im
verwaltungsrat der gotthardbahn mit
dabei haben gar nicht ob er möchte im
verwaltungsrat i know how und das ist
eine weitere schicksal vom es nur der
rücktritt man gezwungen hat sondern auch
dass er trotz seiner unbestrittenen
verdienst große verdienste gott hat das
einmal 1880 in verwaltungs- hat eine
frau geworden ist er beklagt sich bei
welt darüber
ich bin zur überzeugung gelangt dass die
gesellschaft mir die genugtuung schuldig
gewesen wäre mich in den verwaltungsrat
zu wählen
und dass sie in dem sie davon umgang
nahm ein unrecht an mir begangen hat
welty antwortet hätte ich eine ahnung
davon gehabt dass sie aus irgendeinem
grunde eine wahl erwarten
so hätte ich ihnen mit aller
entschiedenheit von einer solchen
abgeraten
sie konnten diese wahl nur als ausdruck
der anerkennung und satisfaktion
wünschen aber diese kann ihnen niemand
der teilen als die öffentliche meinung
oder die unparteiische geschichte
[Musik]
aber es kommt noch dreister als 1880 der
lang ersehnte durchstich am gotthard
erfolgt bekommt alfred escher von emil
welt die nichts als ein dürres telegramm
zur durchstichs feilen göschenen und
airolo wird er nicht eingeladen
er ist übrigens mit keinem wort erwähnt
worden 1808 das muss man sich mal
vorstellen der eine fähigkeit ist der
name nicht gefallen
mit dem stern über fertig geworden und
hätten eigentlich bis es alle infos die
treffer erscheint ein bis 1802 dachte
immer der akku ist wieder sieht man dort
können waren wieder aufgegangen
aber letztlich muss man sagen hätte er
sich von einer verschiedene schläge und
er hat mich nie stecke im zusammenhang
mit dem gros tat er sich noch einen
alfred escher stirbt 63-jährige am
sechsten dezember 1882
aufgebraucht und ausgebrannt der toten
zug mutet an wie ein staatsbegräbnis
sein freund der theologe alexander
schweitzer sagt in der abdankung rede in
der frau münsterkirche in zürich große
männer sind nicht leicht fähig anderen
eben sich aufkommen zu lassen oder gar
zur gleichen höhe heranzubilden treten
sie ab so fehlt es an entsprechenden
ersatz größe stand nicht ohne diese
schranken und leuchtete nicht ohne
diesen schatten zu werfen
die zeitungen würdigen ihn mehrheitlich
mit respekt die nzz beispielsweise
schreibt die republik hatten ihm eine
niere hervorragendsten bürger verloren
der mit seltener hingabe und tatkraft
sich durch ein reich bewegtes leben
hindurch den öffentlichen dingen widmete
kaum ist er tot ist man wieder nett zu
ihm
er bekommt sogar ein denkmal auf dem
zürcher bahnhofplatz seine demontage zu
lebzeiten führt aber doch dazu dass er
lange zeit in vergessenheit gerät
[Musik]
jetzt 125 jahre später anlässlich des
gotthard jubiläums macht man gut was
damals versäumt wurde
visionäre wie er auf die dächer braucht
dieses land unternehmer und politiker
die große zusammenhänge erkennen und
verhindern dass die schweiz auf
abstellgleise der geschichte gerät
und so trifft ein was im weltall frazier
damals prophezeit hatte die späte
satisfaktion der unabhängigen geschichte
montolivo coppo sieht auch bei den
großen komponisten braucht zum teil
jahrzehnte wenn nicht jahrhunderte bis
sie ihre bedeutungen erkannte man darf
nicht vergessen
125 jahre das tönt zwar noch viel aber
in der geschichte der menschheit ist es
nichts was ein kleiner moment trotzdem
stellt sich die frage warum alfred
escher ausgerechnet in der heutigen zeit
ein solches revival erlebt
die zielführung sicher die vw und bürger
vor riesenprobleme sehr viele leute zu
nach dem start wird nach 16 machina
forum und die probleme gelöst aber das
heißt dass wir bis vor superman und
passen die die heute gezielt die heutige
zeit ist die zeit der nähert und der
direkten demokratie mit ihrer geteilten
verantwortlichkeit aber würde sich der
heutige verkehrsminister nicht auch ein
solches denkmal wünschen das projekt
verantwortlich sondern sich die ganze
direkte demokratie also
christoph matschie und ehrlich sein ich
möchte auch das schießen immer noch
übertroffen
[Musik]